bon beau et bio c'est la maxime qui
anime la maison blanche situé à
versailles les tablettes de chocolat
reprennent d'ailleurs le damier de la
cour de marbre du château une
originalité yvelinoise jusqu'à
l'emballage
le gérant a voulu habiller ses tablettes
en toile de jouy
c'est un peu l'équivalent du burberry
anglais si vous voulez c'est tout le
monde s'est un peu approprié cette cette
toile très baroque mais c'est un
marqueur assez fort ancré dans la
tradition dans une forme de classicisme
à la française et c'est comme ça qu'on
voulait aussi imaginer maison blanche
créé il ya bientôt deux ans l'entreprise
a une collection de 15 tablettes aux
saveurs particulières lavandin bergamote
cardamome ou encore géraniums l'année
2020 a été compliqué pour cette jeune
société
elle compte sur la période de noël pour
se rattraper 80 % du chiffre d'affaires
de l'année devraient être réalisés ces
prochaines semaines
c'est une période qui rattrapait toute
l'année qui a été catastrophique
et pour le coup elle était très très
bien rattraper le tout la gamme a eu un
beau coup beaucoup de succès dans tous
nos réseaux de distribution et donc bas
les produits ont été appréciées donc on
a on a décuplé les ventes et aujourd'hui
voilà le carnet de commandes est plein
en tout cas et la cadence s'accélère en
fabrication le chocolatier sort en ce
moment 1000 à 1600 tablette par jour au
lieu des 700 à 900 tablettes
habituellement vous êtes dans l'atelier
de production donc vous allez assister
au coulage des tablettes
donc on a le
un moule en polycarbonate avec
l'intérieur qui est gravé en relief de
la cour de marbre du château de
versailles et on va couler tablette à
l'intérieur deux nouvelles tablettes aux
éclats de caramel au beurre salé devrait
voir le jour en 2021